the death stranding trailers look good  and now we know what engine they're  running on I'm Tony and this is your  technical game spot news update today  Okajima has partnered up with guerilla  games the team behind horizon zero dawn  and the Killzone franchise death  stranding runs on the studio's décima  engine which is said to be quite  powerful at handling open-world games  although this does not necessarily mean  Kojima's game is open-world this was all  revealed at a PlayStation experience  panel where Kojima also mentioned the  game will feature some female characters  I wonder which actresses he'll pick for  that death stranding is heading to ps4  and PC at some point in the future and  horizon zero dawn hits ps4 on February  28th we'll have plenty more to say on  both of those games in the coming months  so for all the latest video game news  you're already in the right place